Sara drew or last day her last episode
what was it like that day on set the
whole thing it's unfortunate that's my
partner that's my Road Dogg so it's uh
it was unpleasant but she's such a
professional and did incredible work
down to the last frame and I'm just
really proud to have had our time
together how does that make you feel
it's very apparent that he's the biggest
Sarah Drew fan we had such an incredible
journey we really did we went through as
acting partners and as friends and like
doing the kind of work that we had to do
as acting partners bonds people you just
you just bond doing stuff that is that
heart-wrenching in that intense and and
you know we really cared about how our
story was told and we we rehearsed like
crazy and we talked to the writers and
made adjustments and we were always
thinking ahead and always making sense
of everything you know it felt really
good to have someone that that we could
both 100% lean on one another and trust
one another when we are in those scenes
together we just knew that the other one
would lift the other one up you know I
multiple times it's like hey remind me
why I'm so mad at you because I can't I
can't get it I can't get it and he'd be
like this is why you're mad at me you're
mad at me because of this and this and
this and this go do it you know like and
and we would do that for one another you
know to help elevate each other's
performances so it was sweet it was
special you know it was a really special
working relationship so if the
opportunity ever presented itself to
come back on the show what do you to say
though do you never say never just
because they are my family I mean I I
still love everyone over there I love
that community and I I still have such
an incredible space in my heart for
every everyone over there so I'll
definitely I but I do really I really do
feel like you know because of how it
went down I really had to part ways with
April I just had to there was no way for
me to like live in a
face of possibility of her returning and
also be healthy in my letting go of all
of it
so I really have said goodbye to him
shaking it loose I I have and I've loved
her and I've said thank you to her and
I've enjoyed my journey being with her I
mean she feels like you know an
appendage
she's so I'm she's and she's a beautiful
person it's a long time to embody
someone nine months out of the year so
I'm and I really had to say goodbye to
her so I think saying hello again would
be hard but again I'm not I'll never say
never these days Sarah is focused on her
latest project an inspiring film about
faith and family called indivisible
she's teaming up once again with regress
Anatomy co-star Justin Bruning and lots
more familiar faces
Jason George and Michael O'Neill who
played the shooter in the the big
episode where the shooter came and shot
at the hospital Michael O'Neill plays an
amazing character and then Scott
Marshall he did a guest spot on Grey's
Anatomy on Jay prale the sequel yeah
she's in it she kills it so like with
that we got a lot of fun Grey's Anatomy
contingency yeah I think it's gonna
resonate with with anyone no matter
where they are because I think anyone
has experienced what it means to be in
pain and when you're in pain you want to
feel some sense of hope and and I think
that the the greatest messaging in this
in this movie is even though something
they feel hopeless doesn't mean that it
is hopeless just like what my dad said
to me on my darkest day you know and I
am my hope would be anyone in any kind
of relationship and any kind of it could
be a work situation it can be a marriage
it can be boyfriend girlfriend
girlfriend girlfriend boyfriend
boyfriend whatever be anything if you
were in the dark place know that there
is light at the end of the tunnel my
character has a line in this movie that
kind of ties us in because he goes if
you basically if you find yourself in
this place
and you need help just ask yeah just
just ask that simple
and since that simple
you
[Music]